you know
every time anybody meets my sister they
turn it so what's it like having joe's a
brother you know their comment is for
real
it's been very difficult
let's get in here
okay
thank you
thank you appreciate it nice to see you
pal
thank you jojo see you later
hey
you're gonna put your left hand
do you solemnly swear they will support
and defend the constitution united
states against all enemies foreign and
domestic
that you bear true faith and leases of
the same do you take this obligation
freely
without any mental reservation or
purpose of invasion and that you will
well and faithfully discharge the duties
of the office on what you're about to
enter so help you god
congratulations
hey
there's a lot to smile about tonight
he told us we'd be crowded
well i gotta tell you i have three
brothers when my mom was around they
said
oh your son's like friends he said well
i have three sons now do you know jimmy
jimmy
does he's a businessman and frankie he's
such a handsome sprite boy he's a great
athlete and yes joey what's he do well
he's a lawyer
you think i'm kidding i'm not kidding
that was it
helpful i'm glad to meet you
thank you all right keep the face all
right good
photos i'm working on it we haven't had
the pictures okay
all right
nice to meet you pal remember nobody's
serious to you
i will okay well i'll do it i it's my
son to go to meet him soon
i only bring this out every four years
and we swear people in
it's good
we're going to do this again left-handed
bible right here
do you solemnly swear that you will
support and defend the constitution
united states against all enemies
foreign and domestic
that you bear true faith allegiance to
the same do you take this obligation
freely without
any mental reservation or purpose of
evasion that you will well facing his
charge of duties the office i want you
about then this will help you god
thank you
this is my daughter annelle nice to meet
you great to see you
my son oh we know one another
and my dad hey good to see you my folks
live in kansas city and they're out for
this
i remember monday night
look in my house it was real simple
there's mothers
and then there's something else and
something else and there's mothers and
then there's mothers
so it's you know it works when we button
up here next to mom here i want to make
sure i got this right
this is not a commandment
just an entire person
i hope she does better for you she did
for me
she did for me no she's wonderful
you know my my son that's been doing it
oh i know
no no how many times we run each other i
mean more than
more than he'd like to count more than
he'd like to hear
that's a great job i mean really great
deal
on the trail as they say in southern
delaware mom you've done good
hey how are you doing
oh come on mommy you stand right here
hold this guy so
that's all right and mommy would you
hold this right
do you solemnly swear they will support
independent constituents united states
against all enemies foreign and domestic
that you bear true faith and allegiance
to the same
and that you take this obligation freely
without without any mental reservation
or purpose invasion that you're well on
faith in this charge of the peace and
finances
the office upon which you're about to
enter
hey mom how are you you look like your
sister
my sister hey suzanne how are you
my brother hey ben how are you well come
on let's slide in
all right okay
thank you oh you know what i can tell
is
um
thank you mr vice president all right
hey how are you good to see you
all right mr play you're up hey
congratulations man congratulations
hi how are you joe nice to see you
they're going to have you stand right
there sir
and if you're going to hold the bottom
do you solemnly swear they will support
and defend the constitution united
states against all
enemies foreign and domestic that you
bear true faith and allegiance to the
same that you take this obligation
freely without
any mental reservation or purpose of
evasion that you will well on faith to
discharge your duties of the office upon
which you're about to use to help you
god i
congratulations
no
ready
mom do you realize in parts of arizona
just risked your reputation
thank you so much jeff congratulations
congratulations
best wishes congratulations
i love her then tell her i love her
do you solemnly swear that you will
support and defend the constitution of
the united states against
all enemies foreign to domestic that you
bear true faith allegiance to the same
and
you take this obligation freely without
any mental reservation or purpose of
evasion
that you will well and faithfully
discharge the duties of the office upon
which you're about to enter so help you
god
congratulations senator i hope you
enjoyed as much as i did here thank you
my kids are about the same age
that's a democrat i know but it's okay
oh she cries loudly
congratulations thank you sir all right
thank you and this is my mother oh hey
mom how are you here in wilmington
you're kidding me
i lived there is that right
where'd you live yeah
i love you it's a pleasure to meet you
that's wonderful well come on mom we're
going to put you right next to me here
okay
okay here we go
there you go hey everybody good to see
you you want to stand mom
here we go you stand right there mom
we'll go around you entertainment
okay here we go
thank you okay um
all right but i wasn't encouraging
someone with them no it
hi how are you joe biden how are you
hi hi nice to see you what's your name
hey sis how are you good to see you
how are you
hey man how are you okay
okay
and
crazy
one minute angel do you want to hold it
here you go lollipop
okay just hold it just
oh i guess i guess i'm going to have you
stand right in the middle
okay you got to stand there and i'll you
get in the middle of us okay
he's going to put his left hand up right
here
who do i look at what do
do you solemnly swear they will support
and defend the constitution united
states against all enemies foreign and
domestic
that you bear true faith divisions to
the same and that you take this
obligation freely without
any mental reservation or purpose of
evasion that you will well
and faithfully discharge the duties of
the office upon what you're about to
give god
i do here
thank you we got you we've got some
family come on you guys
this is my daughter molly hey molly how
are you
it's a pleasure to meet you my grandson
josh hey josh
how you doing good to see you again
sister
well how are you i'll tell you what my
sister said brothers were happy to be
carried especially
there's no such thing in my family i
don't believe
hey i'll tell you what great to see you
all right
who's the big guy you can stay right
there slide up and that's all right man
just don't tell bob bird's ghost to let
you show that to you
don't hide don't hide mine she's a star
congratulations everybody enjoy the day
thanks again for your service thank you
so much
he and i go back
she is
you see this is my toughness my mom can
you put that in for me i can't
tell your story
is
all right if you'll place your left hand
in the bible raise your right hand
do you solemnly swear that you will
support and defend the constitution
united states against all enemies
foreign and domestic
that you bear true faith and allegiance
to the savior you take this obligation
freely without any mental reservation or
purpose of evasion
and that you will well and faithfully
discharge the duties of the office on
what you're about to enter so i'll help
you god
i do well thank you thank you
this is my son
great to see you okay nathan you get
next to me over here
all right
you say that to somebody in north dakota
they think it's a fish drop your hands
outside you know
maybe you're in trouble right that'll
tell you to drop your hands to your side
thank you a little too formal right now
i'm taking you off
hey
yeah you were i'll tell you what man
you're okay stayed up late
i'll be darned help make the vote
oh great okay what you're going to do
mom would you mind holding the bible
again we're going to
reenact this and you put your left hand
raise your right
okay you ready do you solemnly swear
that you will support and defend the
constitution of the united states
against all enemies
foreign domestic that you bear true
faith and allegiance to the same that
you take this obligation freely without
any mental reservation
or perfect invasion and that you will
well and faithfully discharge the duties
of the office on which you're about to
enter so i'll help you god
congratulations for that i told you i
hope you enjoy it as much as i do
my
i know
thank you
guys
they're gonna have the bible holder
stand right in the middle
okay yeah
all right do you solemnly swear you will
support and defend the constitution of
the united states against all enemies
foreign and domestic and you bear true
faith and allegiance to the same
that you take this obligation freely
without any mental reservation or
purpose of invasion and that you
will well and faithfully discharge the
duties of the office on what you're
about to do to help you die
congratulations thank you so much
thank you we have we have some family
here this is my mother
mom how are you very cool i'd love to be
very proud of you
you should be saying something helpful
my husband hey corey how are you good to
see you
i want you two guys right in the middle
okay okay
this is our son morgan hey morgan how
are you
hey guys
gentlemen on the other side on the other
side
right behind what you're going to do i'm
going to sleep
all right here we go
good thank you so much thank you so much
go which way that
and she way
thank you very much
thank you so
i thought it was when you got much no i
know i i promise you well
hope i see you again thank you
all right elizabeth congratulations
good to see you i do bruce we're going
to have you
and what i'm going to do you're going to
put your left hand in the bible and
raise your
hand if you would all right and we're
going to do this
you solemnly swear they will support and
defend the constitution of the united
states
against all enemies foreign and domestic
and that you will bear true faith and
allegiance to the same
that you take this obligation freely
without any mental reservation or
purpose of evasion
and that you will well and faithfully
discharge the duties of the office i
want you about them to help you god
time
nice to meet you
please
how are you man congratulations
we're going to have you stand back make
you stand there
you stand right here and okay
okay you
defend the constitution of the united
states americans to all enemies foreign
and domestic
that you bear true faith and allegiance
to the same that you take this
obligation freely
without any mental reservation or
purpose of innovation that you will
well and faithfully discharge the
business of the office upon which about
there is
what happened to the rest of my family
out there
they all came from hawaii they need to
be in this structure don't you think
yeah come on everyone
take your time
where's my family they're coming come on
everybody
you guys come on this side do we have
any more do we have any others
come on then take your time that's right
you're so gracious
come on over this side how are you oh
very well
bit
exactly right thank you
you stand right in the middle can you
stand over in that
right there okay re-enact the oath okay
ready yep do you solemnly swear that he
will support and defend the constitution
united states against all enemies
foreign and domestic
that you bear true faith and legions of
the same you take this obligation freely
without any mental reservation or
purpose of evasion
and they will well and faithfully
discharge the duty of the office upon
which you're about to enter to help you
god
congratulations senator thank you very
much congratulations mom
congratulations do you have any family
yeah okay
hey man my brother hey what's your name
good to see you man how are you doing
man great to be with you
he's a commander made in the army he
looks
okay here we go that looks great
great now were you again i was not
[ __ ] here
all right figures the big boy over there
right
oh
and you're never going to do that
oh
thank you
all right guys
that's it all right guys thanks for your
patience
appreciate it see you all later thanks
see you guys
okay
okay
thank you
coming up here on c-span 3 at 3 p.m
eastern
house speaker john boehner will hold a
mock ceremony
to bring in the new members of the 113th
congress
right now before the swearing-in today
arizona republican senator jeff flake he
joined us this morning on washington
journal
here's that interview now with jeff
flake
we are going across the capitol this
morning to the russell rotunda
where we are joined by senator elect
jeff flake he's member of congress of
the house
now crossing over to the senate since
you're new
since you're not new excuse me senator
elect jeff flake let's just get right to
it you voted no
two days ago on this fiscal cliff
agreement when it comes to raising the
debt ceiling
in a month or so what will be your vote
well i think we've got to use every
avenue we have to
to drive home the point that we're
overspending there is no bigger issue
no bigger issue right now than the
overspending that we're doing
and the effect of our debt and our
deficit on the economy
and on our ability to function as a as a
government and as a country so uh yes i
think we ought to use it to
the full extent to make sure that we cut
spending somewhere
we didn't in this last package so for
you then uh congressman does that mean
that medicare
and cutting spending for medicare is on
the table because when you ran
for the senate seat you know you you
accused your opponent of supporting
medicare cuts and obviously from the
state of arizona a very large elderly
population so is is medicare on the
table for you you bet
and i've said from the very beginning in
every uh campaign event i've been to and
every
forum i've been to that we've got to
change uh the structure
uh to make it uh sustainable in the long
term i i support
the ryan plan i support premium support
for example
we've got to raise the retirement age uh
we've got to
uh with social security uh do the
chained cpi
there are a lot of things we need to do
um and it's not going to be just one or
another it's probably all of them
and and so for for you jeff flake um who
should do who should be doing the
negotiating do you think because in this
last round we just saw that it was vice
president joe biden
right and uh and your leader over there
in the senate mitch mcconnell
right i hope that it's a regular order
uh that's one thing that
we've seen in the 113th or 112th
congress that
has has not been good we've moved away
from regular order we haven't done
appropriation bills one by one in the
house we've certainly tried
but with the senate not one
appropriation bill went through
so my preference is to go through
regular order when you put a bill on the
floor and allow
members to amend it uh that's the best
route and i hope that's what we get back
to
and congressman what about filibuster
reform uh we're reading this morning
that that could be a vote that happens
later on maybe in february and
how they would change it is that you
wouldn't need 60 votes to just consider
a bill or end debate there would be
still over 60 vote requirement on final
passage but
allow a vote allow legislation to at
least come to the floor
how would you vote on that oh i i hope
that we do not change
uh rules that have served this country
well for more than 200 years
uh the senate there's great tradition
here uh the rules are such
that the majority just doesn't have its
will
in the house you know if you have just a
one person majority and a body of 435
you can pretty much control what goes on
that's not the case in the senate
and that's a good thing what we need
here in the senate is a change in
behavior
and i think that that extends to both
sides of the aisle
we can't fill the tree uh meaning you
can't take away the opportunity
for the minority party to have
amendments
but the minority party has to realize
that you can't be dilatory either
so i think we need some behavior changes
but not
changes to the rules uh that that was
considered a couple of years ago
by republicans wiser heads prevailed and
and it didn't happen
i hope the same happens this time uh
senator elect jeff flake
immigration reform being from the state
of arizona
are you willing to compromise on that
and what do you see as compromise
yeah i've been working on this issue for
the entire time that i've been in the
house
i introduced legislation with luis
gutierrez from illinois i worked with
senator kennedy
when we were looking at a bicameral
package as well so yes
we've got to have a bicameral bipartisan
package
that moves through if as long as it
includes
meaningful border security that's what
we really need in arizona
then we've got to do all of it and
obviously it'll be a compromise bill
but it needs to happen all right first
phone call here comes from
thomas in blackville south carolina
democratic caller
all right good morning brother mike
street
and uh also i want to take up a little
bit i
i'm a avid speaker fan watcher i don't
call very much
but uh i am an avid uh c-span watcher
and uh i wanted to take up for you just
a little bit
because you were accused of being
partisan yesterday by
some uh right wing nut from
i forgotten where it was but i think if
you come as close
to getting it right straight down the
middle
as anybody anybody in any place that i
know of
and um it is an honor to speak to uh
senator elect uh flake and uh from
arizona great state
love it love this whole country um
but uh i am i am disturbed
about um some of the things that i see
i'm for filibuster reform and it is not
a 200 year old
thing is the senator said uh i'm a
student of history that's got a law
degree
and i just want you to know that
that filibuster reform is needed
with their independence what they try to
do to the president
and to the advantage of the stimulation
of their own party uh
is bad and that's what caused
these kind of things i'm not saying we
don't have plenty of room on both
sides there's plenty of blame for iran
but uh you know they're gonna have to
the republicans gonna have to get to
get their head out saying all right mr
flynn
hey i would just say that uh you know we
have had changes uh to the rules in the
senate but they've all been done
uh by a super majority margin and and
here we're talking about by a simple
majority just 51
pretty severely changing the rules
particularly on on
how you proceed to a bill and and that
shouldn't be taken lightly and i think
it will backfire
what we need in the senate is is a body
that's different from the house
i've been in the house for 12 years the
rules in the house are appropriate for
the house
but the rules that we have in the senate
are appropriate for the senate and they
shouldn't be changed willy-nilly
mr flake though your colleague from
arizona senator john
mccain uh is proposing some sort of
filibuster reform along with carl levin
has he reached out to you have you told
him you're a no vote
on his proposal well we we haven't fully
studied that proposal i've still been in
the house
so they're trying as happened you know a
couple of years ago when republicans
were
considering this so-called
constitutional or nuclear option
a group the group gang of 14 at that
time came together with a package
but that was was basically an agreement
i i hope that we reach
some kind of similar agreement that
doesn't uh require a changing of the
rules
and if it does that it would just change
standing rules that were last for two
years
rather than rules that would be
perceived to change
uh the rules forever in the body so i
i'm glad that uh
there's a you know bipartisan group of
people working on this and
i i hope to look at that package now
okay
on our republican line keith in portage
indiana
good morning hi good morning good
morning i don't understand it
you know how many wars have we won you
can't even win a war
to protect our borders okay
can't win a war on drugs all right
can't reform anything that's sensible
all right sometimes you gotta go
backwards to go
forward alright they're
stuck in reverse they can't
understand that in order to go
forward sometimes you gotta back up
in order to go forward so no you have to
reform
things that have gotten out of hand over
generation after generation okay
sometimes there's people out there that
have their hands extended out
generation after generation so far
they don't know when to pull them back
in
that free handout has gotten stuck out
so far that generation after generation
only knows to have their hands stuck out
because that's all they've been raised
on
all right mr flake well it's a pretty
broad topic uh
if the caller's suggesting that you have
too many people
who expect too much of government i
think that that's true
that's true across society
i think it's true with uh big companies
it's true with individuals it's
it's true with just about everyone i'm a
believer in limited government
and so i think that uh yeah we need to
return to a more limited government i
think that was envisioned by the
founding fathers
and certainly when you have a government
now that is 16 trillion dollars
in debt uh that that says enough on its
own
our next caller is one of your
constituents sir it's craig in tucson
arizona go ahead craig
yeah congratulations jeff thank you i'm
uh
i'm one of the boys who voted for you
hey i appreciate that
i know you have your hands full we do
thank you um my main concern right this
minute
is how do things like these pork barrel
things get added
to these these uh bills for instance
like
the sandy hurricane release
i got no problem spending money to help
them people
but i don't want it doubled for other
people
how does this happen i've been told that
the senate
was the ones that added those
it just blows me away that
good legislation can start
and all of a sudden it turns to crap
all right mr flake well that that
happens all too frequently uh
fortunately in the house and the senate
over the past uh few years we have done
something that's positive in that regard
uh earmarks where the the biggest bill
with their marks in it i think had
6 300 earmarks or add-ons that was i
think the 2005 transportation bill
we don't do that anymore at least we've
declared a moratorium for now and that's
a good thing
but there's still far too much of that
that goes on and referring to the sandy
relief
there are some legitimate needs there
and legitimate responsibilities
for the federal government there was
insurance that was purchased
that that fund is running low and that
money is owed and congress ought to
appropriate it
having said that i think that items were
added on to that legislation
as a caller said that that really have
little to do with the disaster
senate republicans tried to pair that
back they offered an amendment that was
defeated
the house is going to take it up and if
it comes back to the senate i'll
certainly keep your uh
your thoughts in mind so does that i
appreciate it
um mr flake are you then able to
try to amend it if it when it comes back
to the senate well we don't know what
if we don't know how the house will
consider it if they
concur with the senate bill then there
would not be an opportunity but if they
change it
they're likely will so i i'm one who
believes that
you ought to pay for the disaster and
what the federal government's
responsibility is but
but we can't uh get into the the habit
of
of trying to solve everything for the
future
when one disaster happens some of these
mitigation funds that are put together
really like i said have little to do
with the disaster uh
but uh but really are costly and we need
to
make sure that this to the extent
possible goes through the regular
appropriations process
uh the the problem is sometimes when you
do bills like this
there are legitimate needs that have to
happen immediately
but we put in items that should be
considered
under regular order as a caller said
we have a lot better legislation when
the committees hear these bills
and then we amend them and we do it
through regular order that's what
we need to get back to particularly in
the senate we haven't had that process
for a while
and you were now when you were in the
house as you know someone who who fought
against ear marks right
what will you do in the senate will you
team up with a tom coburn for example
and come to the floor like he does and
offer amendment after amendment to cut
out spending
you bet that's what i've done in the
house i did offer
literally hundreds of amendments there
and
earmarks are now gone i hope they stay
where they are and and i'll work with
senator coburn and
senator toomey senator mccaskill
and others who have worked to ensure
that this ban is in place
i hope that it stays all right sag
harbor new york may is next democratic
caller
uh hello representative blake um the
christian conservative narrative has
been that president obama's a secret
muslim and that he's going to try to
chip away
at our constitutional rights i want to
know
what do you plan to do to stop this
fear-mongering of the republican party
and actually
work to solve the real problems that the
people have such as gun control
renewable energy
and creating jobs well i
like i said i've i've never i've never
been a birther i've never
gone down that road i i respect the
office of the president and i respect
the president
and and i i hope that uh that we
address the issues as you say and uh
rather than
just personalities i think this is
something that afflicts both the
republicans and the democrats
sometimes as we vilify individuals
rather than then look at the issue so i
take your point and
certainly agree with it tom is a
republican in virginia beach go ahead
tom
yes uh good morning congressman flake
how you doing today sir
great to talk to you tom um i i've got a
question i
joined the u.s navy in 1992
just retired yesterday from the military
have several
deployments combat related deployments
i'm a
i'm an amputee and
i have absolutely no disability benefits
given to me through the va
or the military and you know being an
empty and a combat
veteran i'm concerned you know this new
idea system that was put in place for
um individuals with
medical conditions applying through the
va for
compensation was supposed to be taking
care of me
you know to have benefits upon
retirement and here i am
retired as of yesterday have no
nothing that states that i'm a disabled
veteran so i can't even get the 30
hiring you know uh
uh hiring um benefits through the
government
and i i'm just i'm concerned because you
know i should have been compensated for
my service to my country and i'd like to
know what you're gonna do about this
well well thank you i i other than just
hearing on the phone and thank you for
your service
by the way but i i i don't know your
individual circumstance or how the law
applies to it i would certainly
encourage you to talk to your own
member of the house and your your own
senators uh to see if they can follow up
but uh my in general i i think we owe a
debt of gratitude and we also
uh owe those who have served our country
and have been uh
uh wounded in in in battle or in the
course of duty
uh we we certainly need to ensure that
we
uh carry out whatever was promised and
uh that's that's my commitment
uh mr flake have you uh figured out
where the bathrooms are over in this
anatomy who are you talking to
to learn your way around the senate you
know it's it's i've found out now why
it's a six year term over here is
because uh
i can't really figure out how to assign
an office for for several months uh or
maybe a year who knows
it's a different uh institution uh that
uh
i'm finding my way around and it helps
certainly to have been in the house
uh but the senate moves uh more slowly i
think that's by design
but uh with with office space i think
i've avoided the double wide in the
russell rotunda that i'll be in the
basement for a while
in temporary space and what about
committee assignments where would you
like to
where would you like to sit i believe
that's going to be announced today so i
don't want to be premature
but uh let's just say that oh come on i
think you can make some news on the
washington journal
let's just say i i have an interest in
in foreign policy i've
lived overseas and served on the foreign
affairs committee
in the house there are also a lot of
arizona issues that have to do with
public lands
resource power generation those kind of
things that
we need to make sure that we continue
senator kyle has held this seat for 18
years
and and he has worked hard to make sure
that those issues were addressed in
arizona water
settlements things like that that i plan
to take up as well
all right center-elect jeff flake thank
you sir hey thanks for having me on
coming up live at 3 p.m speaker of the
house john boehner holds a mock
swearing-in ceremony on capitol hill
with new and re-elected house members
until then
an interview from earlier today with
freshman wisconsin democratic
congressman
mike pocan
inside the cannon rotunda we're joined
by mark pocan he's the democrat of
wisconsin new
to the house so what's your background
what do you bring to the table here
sure well um i've had a small business
for over half of my life so
24 years i had hair and it was dark when
i first opened it so i
have a lot of small business experience
a union printing business
so a little bit of labor a little bit of
management
background also i've spent 14 years in
our wisconsin
legislature six of those years on our
budget writing committee and i
co-chaired that when the democrats were
in charge so
a good background in government a good
background in the private sector
and looking forward to making both of
those halves
help in my new job here how did you win
the seat um
you know i have a great district and i
think because i've had a long reputation
there whether it be working
in the legislature or with non-profits
or through the business i had enough of
contacts with people that i think it
really helped out so the district is
about six
counties in uh south central wisconsin
madison is probably the biggest city
within there and i've lived there for
the last 30 years so
i think my background and being there
for a long time really helped
your priorities for the 113th congress
one is just
getting something done would be like a
nice first start maybe
um you know i i'm always amazed at you
know how tough it's been around here for
people to be able to get anything done
and work together
and you know i'm a progressive democrat
but at the same time i've got a
reputation for working with people
across the aisle
it's the only way i really know it's
kind of a wisconsin way and hopefully i
can bring some of that
out here to washington you know there's
caucuses like the problem solvers caucus
that no labels is trying to do and i'm
gonna try to join that it's trying to
make democrats and republicans get
together
and talk to each other it's pretty
simple it would seem to most real people
but
around here i know they have a real
difficulty with it so i'm looking
forward to trying to
you know bridge that gap you know stick
to my values and represent my district
but work with people
and who are you replacing tammy baldwin
who is going to the senate
she and i were on the county board 21
years ago i helped her get elected to
the legislature to congress
she's an amazing person she'll be an
amazing senator and i couldn't be more
happy
you suspect you have a similar record to
hers and very similar i mean i think you
know as far as our philosophies
um you know we had a little different
path in the legislature of things that
we did but
she's an amazing person and i'm very
happy to be succeeding her
and were your priorities beyond
um sort of the just getting people to
work together right exactly that's a
real focus i i think another thing that
i've always stood for in the legislature
is
fighting for the middle class i think
the special interests have plenty of
people in washington to represent them
but i think real people need people to
represent them and coming from a labor
background like i am
i really want to be here to represent
the average person and make sure we're
getting a fair shake when all the
special interests want something
especially as we're doing major things
like
tax revisions and all the rest that
we've got to figure out in the code
let's make sure that we're defending the
middle class first
president obama has said when it comes
to the debt ceiling vote one of your big
votes
first big votes out here he does not
want to negotiate on that that
republicans are saying well medicare and
social security they need to be on the
table
before we agree to raise the debt
ceiling your take
well i would hope that at some point i
just watched all the rhetoric with the
fiscal cliff
and in the ineptness of what happened
i'm hoping that people will start to
hear from their constituents and realize
that
things like social security medicare
people really need those are things that
people really
if you're at that level getting those
benefits that's how you often get by
versus trying to talk about some of the
other issues around the debt ceiling
i think we need to have a longer term
view not doing things for a few months
at a time and that's one of those things
i'm afraid that
that could happen again we'll get back
to deciding things a couple months at a
time rather than actually getting
something done so
i'm hoping that people will maybe rise
up a little uh
and start calling their their
representatives and maybe we can get
somewhere in a more reasonable way we
can't get worse than the last congress i
think we just have to try to be better
committee assignments do you know yours
so far oversight and reform and then we
should be getting another one i believe
within the next week
and what are you looking for as a
freshman i'm looking for
anyone any committee but uh my
background in budgeting obviously would
be something that could be helpful in
the budget committee
i also have a lot of interest in foreign
affairs given my district the uw madison
and a lot of folks at international
interest yeah okay yeah
all right well first phone call comes
actually from one of your constituents
alex
in madison wisconsin democratic caller
hi alex are you there yeah hi you're on
the air go ahead
hi mark um great to see you in
washington and great to see you
doing what you're doing there you
mentioned earlier that
you know you're known for your district
from being someone who reaches across
the aisle
um being able to work and i think at the
same time what we've been seeing in that
we found a 112
com congress was an inability to do that
and right now congress has one of the
lowest
ratings